y
[Música]
ya son al menos 28 los fallecidos en
américa central por el paso de la
tormenta y ota a medida que pasan las
horas se conoce la magnitud de la
tragedia en colombia nicaragua panamá y
honduras hoy en el salvador ya es una
depresión tropical a esta devastación se
le suman las afectaciones por la
pandemia de covite shimano
el parlamento alemán aprobó una
legislación que da al gobierno los
poderes necesarios para imponer
restricciones por la pandemia la
iniciativa generó enfrentamientos entre
la policía y los manifestantes que
rechazan la imposición de nuevas medidas
contra el joven 19
y en eeuu retiro cargos por drogas
contra el ex ministro de defensa
mexicano salvador cienfuegos y entregara
la investigación a mexico
así el militar podrá ser juzgado en el
país azteca el presidente lópez obrador
dijo que no habrá impunidad
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias aquí en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz al menos 28 personas
han muerto en centroamérica tras el
devastador paso del huracán yo está que
llego al salvador como tormenta tropical
en la isla de colombiana de providencia
y otra dejó una destrucción del 98 por
ciento de la infraestructura llegó como
categoría 4 a nicaragua dejando más de
20 muertos además de árboles caídos
viviendas destruidas en la vecina
honduras ya ha dejado de exportar
mientos de ríos yo está hoy se cataloga
como una depresión tropical
la precaria situación de estos países
por donde ha pasado yo está ya estaba
gravada por la pandemia de kobe 19 las
infraestructuras destruidas en muchas
zonas las inundaciones el hacinamiento y
la falta de agua potable dificultan la
lucha contra el coronavirus marina da
sardiña amplia en el siguiente informe
temporada de huracanes en tiempos de
pandemia un cóctel que agrava aún más la
situación de emergencia sanitaria y
económica en centroamérica por el kobe
19 el impacto de la tormenta tropical y
ota deja un reguero de devastación a su
paso que se suma a los impactos del
virus en una región donde la
vulnerabilidad de las personas y las
desigualdades eran ya alarmantes la
región ha sido golpeada por la pandemia
de kobe 19 que actualmente cuenta con
más de 260 mil casos registrados las
organizaciones humanitarias alertan
sobre un posible aumento de contagios
como consecuencia de los huracanes y el
hacinamiento en albergues donde hay unas
30.000 personas en nicaragua país de
entrada de la depresión tropical el
número de contagios roza los 6000 y
cuenta con al menos 159 muertos pero las
asociaciones médicas nicaragüenses han
insistido al gobierno en que muestre los
datos reales de la pandemia mientras que
en honduras las deficiencias del sistema
sanitario precarizaron el trabajo de la
primera línea de batalla contra la
enfermedad de los hospitales donde más
de 70 miembros del personal médico
fallecieron por el cob y 19 cifras del
pasado agosto son víctimas de un sistema
que
envío
a pelear una guerra sin los insumos
necesarios para poder tener
en la posibilidad de triunfar y el
salvador donde desde el inicio de la
pandemia se impusieron fuertes
restricciones de movilidad registran más
de 36.000 positivos guatemala es el país
con más decesos por la pandemia
centroamérica con casi 4.000 y suma más
de 115 mil contagios por su parte
colombia uno de los países más golpeados
en américa latina' sus islas caribeñas
de san andrés y providencia cuentan con
dos mil cuatro contagios pero las
infraestructuras han quedado totalmente
arrasadas por el huracán las
inundaciones y la falta de insumos que
dificultarán aún más la lucha contra la
pandemia con una abrumadora mayoría de
415 votos a favor y 236 en contra el
parlamento alemán aprobó una legislación
que otorga al gobierno los poderes
necesarios para imponer nuevas
restricciones con el fin de frenar el
brote de kobe 19 mientras se discutía el
proyecto miles de personas salieron a
protestar en el centro de berlín contra
los planes de la canciller alemana
angela merkel
las nuevas medidas pueden prohibir el
contacto social e imponer el uso de
mascarillas beber alcohol en público y
restringir la movilidad
[Aplausos]
la defensa de la salud no es algo
absoluto pero hemos decidido que la
defensa de la salud en esta pandemia
recibirá un peso relativamente alto
hemos decidido por amplia mayoría tanto
en este parlamento como en la sociedad
que no aceptaremos que nuestro sistema
sanitario se desborde que no podemos
evitar el dolor por la enfermedad uso de
medicamentos o la muerte pero lo
intentaremos aliviar en la medida de lo
posible philips lite a psm prisión
siendo el laboratorio farmacéutico fac
ser dijo que los resultados finales de
la última etapa del ensayo de su vacuna
contra el nuevo corona virus en alianza
con variante que tiene una efectividad
del 95 por ciento la compañía informó
que cumplió con los dos meses de datos
de seguridad requeridos y por tanto
solicitará la autorización de emergencia
en eeuu para iniciar la producción
moderna también publicó el lunes datos
preliminares para su vacuna que muestra
una efectividad del 94 por ciento frente
al 92 por ciento de la vacuna rusa
la organización mundial de la salud
decretó hoy el fin del brote de ébola
declarado el pasado primero de junio en
el noroeste de la república democrática
del congo la epidemia fue la undécima
que sufrió el país que reportó 130 casos
55 muertes y 75 contagios que se curaron
lado ms aseguró que superar uno de los
patógenos más peligrosos del mundo en
comunidades remotas y de difícil acceso
demuestra lo que es posible cuando la
ciencia y la solidaridad se unen
vamos a américa latina' del gobierno
mexicano dijo que está atento al
traslado del ex secretario mexicano de
defensa el general salvador cienfuegos
luego de que la justicia estadounidense
anunció al retiro de los cargos de
narcotráfico y lavado de activos en su
contra la decisión de washington fue
dada a conocer en un comunicado conjunto
entre méxico y eeuu con este cambio el
general quien está detenido en la unión
americana desde octubre podrá ser
juzgado en el país azteca el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador aseguró que
el retorno del acusado no es signo de
impunidad sino de investigación
cienfuegos podría regresar hoy mismo a
la nación que seguirán su proceso en
mexico que retornarán en nuestro país
significa
[Música]
que será aplicar las leyes méxicanas
porque los hechos a los que hace alusión
la investigación que he comentado de
eeuu se cometieron en territorio
mexicano presumiblemente el presidente
argentino alberto fernández envió al
congreso un proyecto de ley en un nuevo
intento por legalizar el aborto
de ser aprobado marcaría un antes y un
después en la nación sudamericana donde
hasta el momento este procedimiento es
considerado un delito en la mayoría de
los casos para esta tarde se esperan
movilizaciones de colectivos feministas
que exigen que la propuesta prospere en
el legislativo luego de que el senado la
rechazara en 2018
natalia plazas nos ampliará el siguiente
informe
es una nueva oportunidad para la
legalización del aborto en argentina el
presidente alberto fernández envió al
congreso un proyecto de ley que
legalizaría la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo y garantizaría el acceso
público a este procedimiento
la criminalización del aborto de nada ha
servido
solo ha permitido que los abortos
ocurran clandestinamente en cifras
preocupantes
el debate pues no es decirle sí o no al
aborto los abortos ocurren en forma
clandestina y ponen en riesgo la vida y
la salud de las mujeres que a ellos se
someten
por lo tanto el dilema que debemos
superar y si los abortos se practican en
la clandestinidad o en el sistema de
salud de argentina en este país de
mayoría católica el aborto es
considerado un delito salvo en casos de
violación o aquellos en que la salud o
la vida de la mujer está en peligro pero
esto podría cambiar
y yo creo que tenemos posibilidades para
hacer como siempre los votos pueden
estar muy ajustados nunca va a haber una
votación con mucha diferencia de votos
pero tenemos confianza yo creo que
también han pasado cosas se han visto
las muertes que se han producido desde
2018 para acá en 2018 argentina estuvo
cerca de legalizar el aborto hasta las
14 semanas de embarazo pero aunque la
propuesta fue aprobada en la cámara
quedó detenida en el senado desde
entonces un fortalecido movimiento
feminista ha hecho de la legalización
del aborto uno de sus principales
reclamos una nueva manifestación para
exigir su aprobación se da cita el
miércoles ante el congreso en el país
cada año cerca de 38 mil mujeres son
hospitalizadas por abortos mal
practicados y desde 1983 3000 mujeres
han muerto por esta causa
vamos a europa este miércoles francia
marca un hito tecnológico el lanzamiento
de las primeras redes móviles del 5g del
país el regulador de telecomunicaciones
de la nación ha aprobado el despliegue
con la oposición de varios líderes
mundiales y activistas por
preocupaciones sobre los efectos
ambientales y en la salud
la activación de las redes 5g en vivo en
parís y otras ocho ciudades francesas la
próxima generación de datos móviles
promete una velocidad de transmisión
hasta 10 veces más rápida que la 4g con
mucho menos retraso en el tiempo de
conexión los proponentes esperan que sea
crucial para el desarrollo de vehículos
autónomos intervenciones médicas y
fábricas conectadas junto con mejores
experiencias de realidad virtual y
entretenimiento pero su despliegue se ha
enfrentado a un importante retroceso en
francia- debido a la preocupación por el
aumento de la demanda de energía un
creciente problema de residuos
eléctricos y la explotación de recursos
no renovables junto con un temor a la
pérdida de privacidad en medio de la
creciente recolección de datos y el
potencial impacto en la salud por una
mayor exposición electromagnética
podríamos pedir que se prohíba a las 5 g
pero solo pedimos un debate un estudio
sobre el impacto de la sonda 5g queremos
información sobre el impacto en la salud
y el efecto en la demanda de energía
estas preocupaciones han llevado a
docenas de funcionarios franceses a
pedir una moratoria de la 5g mientras
tanto las teorías de conspiración
la tecnología con el kobe 19 han
contribuido a unos 50 ataques
incendiarios de antenas 5g en todo el
país los operadores de redes franceses
han desembolsado cerca de 28 mil
millones de euros al estado por bloques
de frecuencia 5g pero el país está
actualmente muy por detrás de muchos
vecinos europeos en su despliegue hasta
ahora se han instalado menos de 500
antenas la autoridad de
telecomunicaciones en francia quiere que
dos tercios de la población tenga acceso
a 5g para 2025 con un acceso total que
no llegaría hasta 2030 en francia se
discute un proyecto de ley controvertido
sobre seguridad global que divide
incluso dentro de las filas de la
mayoría parlamentaria de manuel macro en
la difusión de las imágenes de los
agentes de policía prevista por el
ministro del interior está en el punto
de la mira ya que las disposiciones es
la que causa más controversia dentro del
proyecto de ley
1300 enmiendas presentadas para este
proyecto de ley sobre la seguridad
global 32 artículos que prevén en
particular más misiones para la policía
municipal más regulación de la seguridad
privada y la creación de un marco legal
para la vigilancia policial por medio de
drones el artículo 24 que trata de la
difusión de imágenes de policías creará
un nuevo delito si se adopta difundir
por cualquier medio y sobre cualquier
soporte con el fin de causar daños
físicos o psicológicos a su integridad
física o psíquica la imagen del rostro o
cualquier otro elemento de
identificación de un funcionario de la
policía nacional o de un miembro de la
gendarmería nacional cuando actúe en el
marco de una operación policial sanción
por este nuevo delito un año de prisión
y una multa de 45.000 euros
creed y zetas cual es el propósito de
este artículo y proteger a los agentes
de policía que a veces son víctimas de
amenazas o agresiones pero sin
prohibición de filmar quiero ser claro
fue este caso para ningún límite para la
grabación de acciones policiales
entonces pero se podría buscar justicia
si se comprueba que la difusión de las
imágenes tuvo la intención de dañar los
sindicatos de periodistas denuncian un
intento de socavar la libertad de
información para las asociaciones que
hacen campaña contra la violencia
policial es una forma de limitar la
publicación de estas imágenes videos que
a veces pueden ser utilizados como
prueba cuando los funcionarios de la ley
están implicados a petición de la liga
de derechos humanos las naciones unidas
han publicado un informe sobre el
proyecto de ley y considera que puede
conducir a la violación de las
libertades fundamentales
miles de personas se manifestaron
nuevamente y de manera pacífica en la
capital de tailandia para exigir
reformas democráticas a la constitución
las movilizaciones se daban mientras el
parlamento rechazaba varias de estas
propuestas desde julio los manifestantes
exigen una nueva carta magna para que el
senado se elija democráticamente se
reduzca el poder de los militares y
piden que se limite la influencia de la
monarquía en la política
los aviones boeing 737 max podrán volver
a transportar pasajeros la
administración federal de aviación de
eeuu retiró la prohibición que habían
impuesto tras los fatales accidentes con
este tipo de aeronaves en indonesia en
2018 y etiopía en 2019 que dejaron más
de 300 personas muertas los
investigadores habían atribuido los
accidentes a una serie de fallas de la
empresa pero la agencia estadounidense
dijo que los cambios en el software el
diseño y la capacitación hicieron que la
aeronave fuera más seguros
y hasta aquí esta emisión de noticias en
france 24 muchas gracias por
acompañarnos recuerden que pueden seguir
la actualización de nuestras noticias en
nuestra página web www puntos francia 24
punto com
[Música]